ever since democrats came out swinging
against florida's parental rights in
education bill which bans sexual
conversations from kindergarten through
third grade classrooms the libs have
found themselves on the receiving end of
a new political slogan
okay groomer
some conservatives think this slogan is
hyperbolic and counterproductive i for
one think it's great
after years of democrats bandying about
the word racist unfairly to destroy
people's lives and shut down debate i am
all for a potentially equally powerful
word like groomer which in this case i
think is being used fairly conservatives
are arguing that if you insist on having
sexual conversations with kids in the
classroom or anywhere else and then
hiding those conversations from their
parents
you are a groomer you are priming kids
for certain kinds of sexual behaviors
for a certain kind of sexual perspective
the attack so far seems pretty effective
according to recent polls the vast
majority of likely voters support the
florida law and oppose sexual
conversations with little kids and yet
despite the popularity of this bill and
other bills
democrats are doubling down all the way
up to the white house which now says
it's going to fight to protect sexual
conversations between teachers and
little kids in florida and all around
the country bad news for kids
bad news for the culture but potentially
bad news for democrats too as voters
head into the midterms pissed off and
eager to protect their kids i always
want to be fair on this issue i do not
want to be a pyromaniac in a field of
straw men and so i have twisted the arm
of my friend jessica tarlov who is one
of if not my very favorite democrat out
there
jessica you know her from the five she's
a host of the five she's vice president
of insights at bustle she is the author
of america in the age of trump
opportunities and oppositions in an
uncertain world if trump runs for
president again we might get a second
run of that book we might get the age of
trump part two
uh so jesse first of all thank you so
much for coming on the show i very much
appreciate it
so i have talked to a colleague of yours
ethan behrman about the substance of
this law in florida the parental rights
and education bill i'm i'd be more than
interested certainly in hearing your
take on the substance but first at least
i want to get to your thoughts as a
political strategist
the opposition to this bill and others
seems to be a total loser for democrats
in virginia in florida in
every poll i've seen on the subject
why are democrats doubling down
well you're right well first of all i
want to know if ethan beerman is
potentially your favorite democrat since
you said i was your favorite you rank so
much higher it's not even close he is
you can't even see him from where you
are on the list well he's actually a
lawyer which i am not so he's probably
good to speak to about the substance of
the bill in a different way um than i am
in terms of this being a loser democrats
have fared very poorly with culture war
issues as of late obviously we had a
good year in 2020 and was able to take
back the presidency
um and control of the senate which made
all the difference um but we do know
that that was obviously affected by the
fact that we were in the midst of a
global health pandemic and we had uh
trump who's a very particular type of
republican on the ballot i know you're a
fan but there are many republicans who
remain uncomfortable with his style
um in terms of
the don't say gay bill which i will
admit when i first heard about this i
then searched for the term don't say gay
in the bill because you would think that
it was in there it is not explicitly in
there it's part it's
it's a quirky slogan it's something that
people think will be catchy it has been
used in a lot of ads here and i think
it's very confusing for a lot of people
now i happen to think that the bill is
dangerous i don't think that there's a
need for it and i've seen a lot of
counter arguments against it
um going back to first of all how often
are these conversations happening and
i'm sure that people would say well one
time is too many but we can't legislate
for an entire state or entire country
based upon outlier issues seen pushback
from teachers who have said that this
means that they can't talk about their
lives with their students and you may
not have known your teacher's first name
or whether they were married or if they
had kids but i went to school here in
new york city and i only called my
teachers by their first names i knew
their entire families who were active
participants
in my school and i ended up just fine
and i have a new daughter and i'm not
you know i had she identifies as a girl
because i said that she identifies as a
girl and she even wears pink sometimes
so i i really don't think that this is
nearly as dangerous as an issue
as republicans would have it be
but i know it's all about politics all
the time and i believe that it is a
winning issue
for them now that we have parents that
are pissed off about crt and now they're
pissed off about sexual indoctrination
at the age of six so uh to your point on
whether this is a real issue or not it
seems to me democrats are running into a
contradiction which is and they ran into
the same contradiction on crt which is
on the one hand they're saying it's not
happening crt is not being taught in the
classroom these conversations are not
happening in kindergarten it's not a big
deal at all but then on the flip side
they say
it's the end of the world if we ban
these conversations if we ban crt from
the classroom or if we ban
sexual conversations from kindergarten
so i'm noticing they're going back and
forth here and i'm not sure if there's a
consensus but if it's if the
conversations aren't happening then
great the law is no big deal it's more
wasted inc in government but hey we've
got a lot of that already so what so
then i come back to this political
question and and it seems you agree with
the political uh
outlook on how this is going to fare for
dems in the midterms so then what
happened are they just crazy have they
just lost their minds and they're
running with a bill that they one don't
think even matters all that much and two
is deeply unpopular with voters
well there's always an issue and it's on
both sides of the aisle between the
extremes right we had that obviously
when the tea party came to power right
the moderate republicans were looking at
them saying this is absolute madness and
we have an extreme left in in our party
right now and the people in the middle
of the moderates that are trying to win
races in virginia and michigan etc are
looking them and saying excuse me could
you please stop talking i don't want
here to fund the police i don't want to
hear about socialized medicine we want
to hear about middle of the road
solutions this is how joe biden won so i
think there's a bit of a communication
problem there because often the most
extreme people have the biggest
platforms they're the most effective on
social media they're kind of screaming
from the rooftops about this but there's
this fundamental problem going on right
now with my party about what we should
be focused on and voters have been clear
they care about inflation and the cost
of living that's it that's really all
they care about we would like to save
ukraine from putin sure
we think afghanistan was bungled
sure but we're happy to be out of the
war etc climate change still a really
big deal but not as big of a deal as
whatever it is a 22
rise in the cost of beef at your average
supermarket so that's what the midterms
is going to be about and the moderate
wing of the party certainly understands
that
the left-wing side of the party i think
is a running in districts that are
probably too safe for their own good and
b just doesn't want to say that they're
listening to polls and that is as
someone who was a former former
political poster now does it for
consumer brands i can tell you that's
where everything's won that's where the
dollars are won that's where the
elections are won and the moderate wing
of the party
is message testing all of that they're
listening to their focus groups and
they're saying this is just a loser for
us and there's too much time to be
having this conversation
that it can go on and on and on and
actually allow republicans to be focused
on these culture war issues which they
have been winning as of late rather than
having to put up their own plans and i
brought this up on the five yesterday
for instance on the health care issue
mitch mcconnell was on a sunday show
last weekend and was asked about well
what's the republican plan so that's a
really good issue i'll get a really good
question i'll get back to you
republicans may very well well win on
the health care issue but they haven't
put forward a plan but with democrats
screaming about these other ancillary
things it won't make a difference
necessarily at the polls and that's
where my frustration with it lies and to
your point about if these conversations
aren't happening i didn't say they
weren't happening at all i'm but i do
remain fundamentally concerned about the
young kid a six seven year old and there
are a lot of people who are gay straight
grow up to be trans etc who say that
they knew that sorry i shouldn't have
said gay straight who are gay who's feel
that they knew that when they were
really young and if they don't feel like
they can talk to their parents about it
why shouldn't they be able to go to
their teachers to have those
conversations and i'm not saying that
parents should be left out of the loop
but if you are someone who believes that
you are born in the wrong body and
they've reported kids as young as four
years old who are saying that or saying
mommy i don't think i'm a girl i think
that i'm a boy
and if they can't say that to their
mommy they need someone who can help
them who they can go to and talk to
about that not to get on puberty
blockers but to have an open
conversation
well okay because that because that
that's an important distinction i think
my response if a child came to my own
child came to me and said i think i'm a
girl even though i'm a boy i i would
tell him as lovingly as gently as i
possibly could i'd say well you're not
you're not a girl you're you might you
might have a psychological condition you
might have seen something on the news
you might just be a little kid who gets
confused about things if it were a
little girl i might say you might just
be a tomboy i'm not denying your
feelings but you'll grow out of it as
most people do
but i would lovingly try to deal with
that and so what you're saying is kids
need a resource if they've got awful
terrible regressive parents but not to
the point to put them on puberty
blockers i think the fear here is and
we're seeing stories all around the
country of this
kids before puberty by definition are
being put on these kinds of drugs there
was a whistleblower just came out of
school nurse who said 11 year olds are
being put on these kinds of drugs
without their parents notification and
so it it does raise this i mean i guess
this is where you get the actual title
of the florida bill parental rights and
education
whose right is if you've got two
fundamentally different world views the
traditional worldview
that says boys if you got a boy's body
then you're a boy and you can't be a
girl secretly they just deny the whole
premise of transgenderism and the new
sort of secular transgender view which
says no your body and your
true self can be totally different you
should deny the body and go on puberty
blockers and whatever else is going to
be
following that well who wins out who
wins i people might think the old
christian view or jewish view or
traditional view is is regressive and
terrible and harmful though by the way
the studies i don't think really back
this up on the efficacy of puberty
blockers at reducing suicidality or
depression but but let's put that aside
for a second
who gets to choose is it the is it the
parents if the who let's say they even
deny transgenderism let's say they even
look on homosexuality with moral
appropriate they're orthodox jews
they're traditional christians whatever
or the teachers who are the
representatives of this new secular
culture
well i think fundamentally that parents
should be responsible for these types of
decisions with their children but even
the example that you talked about the
case of the 11 year old who was put on
puberty blockers
and the school knew and the parents
didn't know that's an 11 year old and
this bill is talking about
five-year-olds through third grade so
that's
right five through eight-year-olds
well that's good yeah they certainly
shouldn't be put on the puberty blockers
and they can't be legally put on puberty
blockers but i'm just saying that we're
not actually that's an extension of this
that is totally separate from that bill
and i think that that's part of the
problem when
we talk this fast and loose about things
like this and so few people actually
read the substance of these bills and
they're just railing about well i heard
this and i heard that instead of getting
getting down to the nitty-gritty of
what's in there so we were talking about
extremely young kids you're not denying
the fact that children you said even my
children could potentially feel this way
and express a concern about their gender
identity but when you said that you
would lovingly say this to them
i could push back easily and say it's
not actually loving of a child who's
coming to you and telling you that
they're struggling with their gender
identity to tell them well it's just not
true
and yeah a little girl like it's fine if
you want to be a tomboy but you're not a
boy
because unless you fundamentally refute
the possibility that transgenderism
exists and
i fundamentally refute it i think it's a
complete fantasy i think it's uh not to
get too down the weeds but i think it's
just a new version of the old gnostic
heresy that says that our bodies and our
souls and really when we're talking
about transgenderism we don't like to
use these theological terms but that's
what we're talking about we're saying my
physical self is totally different from
my metaphysical self and the physical
self should be denied and the
metaphysical self that i at least
imagine should bring the physical body
more in line with what it perceives
itself to be i think it's just bogus i
think it's an old crazy religious heresy
i think it's harmful to everyone who's
involved in it and i think it should be
discouraged and i think when you go from
point zero zero one percent of people
identifying as transgender to now 20.8
percent of gen z identifying as
transsexual or pansexual or some other
gender identity issue
clearly that either alex jones is right
and there's something in the water or or
this is a social phenomenon that's going
on that that is related to how we're
even talking about these things
well alex jones is not right about
anything so
he was right about the frogs he was
right about the frogs yale proved
it i don't even know what you're talking
about but i cannot go along with it and
i try to block out as much alex jones
anything as possible
um
so i do think that
social constructs certainly plays a role
in what's going on in the rise of people
identifying as gay as queer non-binary
transgender etc but
i would posit as well that we are at a
different time culturally where people
are feeling like they can actually speak
honestly and openly about who they are
and not feel like they're going to lose
their jobs not feel like they're going
to be ostracized from society there's
obviously been a huge evolution in terms
of how we treat people
who identify in these ways
and there are a lot of psychiatrists and
you're a lot of things but i don't
believe that you're a psychiatrist
i'm i'm more of a biologist myself
katanji jackson is not but i consider
myself more of a biologist
well as a woman
i can tell you
that
there are plenty of psychiatrists out
there that believe strongly that
transgenderism is something that is real
it's something that also that if it
doesn't get addressed is going to lead
to tremendous spikes and we've seen this
in terms of suicide and self-harm and
depression and i go back to the original
north carolina bathroom bill which
basically came down to who cares
really who cares what some if you want
the left cares
no no no
it was because the right had a problem
with people who identified as the other
gender using that bathroom right yeah
that's the change though right
but isn't that the change previously the
men who identify as women were not
allowed in the women's bathroom the libs
wanted them to be able to use the
women's bathroom and the right said no
but we're not the ones who changed the
rules right
no but it was because republicans
made up an issue they said that these
people were identifying that men who
were identifying as women were going to
go into bathrooms and hurt people
yeah they were that it was just
disordered for them to go in
and that's a huge problem and such a
misrepresentation of the way that
transgender people live and if you
obviously i i have plenty to say about
leah thomas and i played sports up to
the collegiate level
not certainly at the d1 level the d3
level but i i understand that that is a
rich debate that is
very textured
but
to deny transgenderism when so many
people have studied this for their whole
lives and so many people who live this
life have said that they are happier
more effective have better relationships
but i would tell you jesse the the you
know one sometimes they say the plural
of anecdote is not data though frankly i
think it is right the plural of anecdote
actually is data but i've talked to
multiple people who had gender confusion
who even went through the process went
on testosterone started transitioning
and who deeply regretted it i've
probably talked to half a dozen people
who deeply deeply regretted it and wish
that someone told them the truth and
when we talk about who's a psychiatrist
or who's a biologist or i mean really
what we're talking about is who's a
philosopher and who's a theologian and
who's who's talking about this question
that you're bringing up too which is who
are we what is what is our true identity
is our true identity what we perceive it
to be does it have to do with the body
does it have to do with what my teachers
tell me in kindergarten we have to leave
it there because i'm seven minutes over
but you
though
though you may be
you may not be a biologist you may not
be a psychologist you met you may very
well be a philosopher you you do remain
among my top three favorite democrats
and i very much appreciate you coming on
where can people find you
well on fox a lot um on twitter at
jessica tarla but i try not to read my
mentions because i work at fox um
so twitter
basically
wonderful you can find jessica on
twitter find her on fox and i hope find
you back on this show very soon i'm glad
you like that clip now subscribe ring
that bell get the notifications better
yet subscribe to the michael knowles
show on apple podcast spotify stitcher
google play wherever you get your audio
podcasts leave a five star review we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you